one states uneasy preparations for the
unthinkable Hawaii is launching a
program aimed at helping residents and
visitors prepare for a nuclear attack
earlier this month North Korea launched
its first and only successful
international ballistic missile experts
say a weapon like that could reach
Alaska and possibly Hawaii
here's Carter Evans North Korean missile
launches are now much more than just
scary images for more than a million
people living in the Hawaiian Islands
based on what you've seen can a North
Korean missile hit Hawaii yeah I think
there's no question about that Jeffrey
Lewis is a nuclear policy expert at the
Middlebury Institute of International
Studies it's frightening and so we need
to take it seriously but we also need to
be calm and we need to be measured and
we need to know that there are things
that we can do first you duck and then
you'll cover but don't expect those
fifties here are civil defense drills
emergency management officials in Hawaii
are launching a campaign to teach people
what to do in the aftermath of a nuclear
blast we're working on notifications
from Pacific commands so that we can get
the word out to the public quickly get
inside stay inside and stay tuned
once the launch is detected officials
estimate people in Hawaii would only
have about a 15-minute warning before
the missile strikes based on the test
that he's done so far in North Korea
these are smaller devices you put those
in Honolulu in the central Honolulu area
we still have a lot of survivors
it doesn't take out the entire island so
Hawaii's emphasis is on sheltering in
place for up to two weeks to protect as
many people as possible from the
radioactive fallout but for a state with
an economy that relies heavily on
tourism there are concerns in a
statement Hawaii's tourism Authority
expressed support for the effort but
said if reports are misinterpreted about
the state's need to prepare for an
attack this could lead to travelers and
groups staying away from Hawaii Lewis
says preparation for an attack is only
part of the solution a nuclear war is
just such a horrible outcome that every
moment you spend
preparing for it is probably better
spent trying to prevent it from ever
happening for CBS this morning Saturday
Carter Evans Los Angeles